before the video starts guys check our
sponsors and nature's blend they
specialize in premium Ethiopian black
seed products their products are
fantastic health supplements and also
from the Sunnah the website is in the
description link below you can also use
the discount code Salam 10 for 10
percent of their products what are you
guys waiting for
and I got terribly terribly sick with
food poisoning and my plan was to walk
around the island every day it was a
tiny little island then there was this
one one than this Muslim woman
[Music]
hi Eddie so high-level things above
[Music]
yeah
assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends welcome to a another episode
actually we don't even have an impetus
to do some de la we are reacting to
variety of different videos current
affairs things that you guys can benefit
from his mother and child as you guys
know our reaction videos are not just
based on life Patriots but should ha oh
wow and that's it and you just you know
we're not here to do that or waste our
time and your time this is a video that
was sent to me actually really random
they were trying to do another video
today but with this specific video that
was sent to me I feel that it's so
powerful and I think it goes back to you
know our organization Salaam stands with
you alright like you know clap add up
you know I'm gonna find out so this is
Oprah Winfrey interviewing a lady and
this is something that she went through
so this isn't - yeah you ready cool okay
oh right
this is from the pocket sha-la-la-la yes
he's here today inshallah and he was
taken about a moment when you
experienced true and pure grace and you
knew it I was in Indonesia um I was
going through my horrible divorce was 31
I was in a terrible depression I took
myself to this tiny little island and
decided I needed to spend 10 days in
silence to try to have a Truth and
Reconciliation hearing like myself
because I was so full of shame and pain
and I decided I wouldn't speak not a
word for 10 days something I didn't know
anybody went we got a hot on a beach in
this tiny little very poor fishing
island off of Lombok and Indonesia and I
got terribly terribly sick with food
poisoning and my plan was to walk around
the island every day so it was a tiny
little island and there was this one
woman this Muslim woman you know when I
say this island was poor I mean what
these people fished that day is what
they ate for dinner that night you know
and this one woman on the other side of
this island used to see me walking and
she would put her hand on her heart and
smile at me when I walked by and I would
do the same to her and then I got really
sick and I was stuck in my cabin
dehydrated terrified actually thought I
had malaria
and far away from anyone into me and
this woman came and found me something
in her knew that I wasn't well she'd
seen me and she knew I wasn't doing well
anyway but when she didn't see me on my
daily walk she came and knocked on my
door and saw the condition that I was in
and went like this and came back an hour
later with fresh food and fresh water
for me and I just started crying in her
arms and she held me in her arms like I
was her child and and just rocked me and
took care to even know her name didn't
know her name's still down and and by
the way she is my face of Islam whenever
you know whatever conversation in the
world is ever happening about Islam she
is my face with Islam that woman who I
don't know I found it's like you see her
lost Daymond forgive me tell how do you
feel like like what
that's deep my heart is mighty yeah
right why just obviously the actions of
the sister herself are like exemplary of
what a Muslim or Muslim should be like
in terms of serving the community and
just you know like the Prophet SAW Sturm
said smiling in the face of your Bravo
yeah obviously not brothers or anything
here but just smiling in the face of
someone can be charity and you never
know what someone King someone that's
going through and at that point the
sister seems like she's very empathetic
she's or something so she's also a she
actually what does she say folder on our
arm
yeah that's embraced actually now you
know you hold you like hold another baby
yeah yeah you get it you can't Lee can't
fake that
no you can't fake that but that's not
something that you can just fake and be
like oh let me just do this that's what
you see if it seems it seems mad genuine
right pop yeah it's this steep as all
that she says that our sisters the face
of Islam for her like I don't know
that's
one one minute 40 seconds us that's the
fingers and what what what she says I
found her end of it is well like she
goes like this here again this is
profound never you know whatever
conversation in the world was ever
happening about Islam she is my face of
Islam that woman hit do you know what
that means what she said she's seen
basically any media comedy show me any
terrorism or this that whoever all I'm
gonna see are you telling me that I need
you know you're trying to pin directly
tell me that Muslims are like this yeah
I'm gonna be seeing that woman's face
yeah do you know what that means a kid
you would we understand what is
happening here and how the father of
some ham said I only came to perfect the
good character and that one of the
things that's gonna be a million
judgment I repeat this over and over
again because as an OMA we're in such a
state Lackey so superficial state that
what I've memorized the books behind me
where Yanni the Arabic terminology that
we use that we've made the religion so
superficial that we seem someone like
them be like okay he's religious and
this is a sad reality because that
sister who gave her a hug like a baby
and sure that affection of a concern it
is the biggest form of Dawa that you can
ever do that be is a key make whoever
the best guy in the whole wide world
would never ever ever make somebody feel
like that and that has left such an
effect on her that she's saying look
whatever you like that but I will never
forget the woman for the rest of my life
and now are you telling me that if we
were spokes his peak to assist this
sister this female and told her a bit
about Islam you don't think her heart is
opened to receive Rhonda so imagine if
she was going through that depression
and then there was a sister where she
said a man that cop yet yeah doing all
kind of medicine and there's another
video of a disgusting vile slavery
that's that's happened which I don't
want to watch it well I I personally do
not want to watch it
imagine if she was going forth and she
said there was a woman in the veil she
treated me like this
and she's at a loss of hello young
Chauncey so it's a beautiful reminder
for us to understand I will attract our
Ataman how I manage the process sell
them and it is so many happy fun this
you know at the bottom offered if you
read it bro mmm it's so profound and we
haven't even scratched the surface if he
were too busy talking about don't you
talk Roberto he'd do this woman what she
did baba she lived to him this woman saw
tawheed the essence of tennessee we're
not walking
the memory of verses or the fact that
someone from who Heidi yes but what's
most important here is M what I think is
that act the the stop them the lesson
here to be learned is that actions speak
louder than words exactly and and and
that's it wrong you can talk as much as
you like someone's going to be observing
the way you carry yourself then they
could be looking at thinking okay this
is how he did you talk about
can I see yeah okay you talk about Tommy
then the sooner sooner for answer
nationalize enough or whatever it may be
continuously but I don't see that even
actions above your bare record you've
been rude your bit harsh you know this
is where it goes back to a key ally we
can't emphasize enough of it but you can
see the action I do you know what that
woman's going to see into Muslims if
she's in a place and somebody says
Muslims about can obviou does he get out
of here you you're talking about it's
not the Muslims that I know and that is
so profound I feel like I found this
amazing
this video was randomly sensing and
what's up by a number even know I mean I
mean he was just somebody I said no sick
I don't know you walk yeah it was
absolutely amazing and I wanted to share
that with you guys were sisters and for
us to understand you have neighbors
yeah we were speaking to we went when
this attack happened in a in a church in
Sri Lanka we went with the world
surround to give some flowers etc and
what did some people and they were
talking about the neighbors all Muslims
you know you know they really they party
for us
like seriously but and and even so now
a heart stole that it's because there is
no like there's no cure deep in that
woman there in terms of there's no lies
and she's not faking that emotion that
she was at the laws of the law and it's
like think about it yeah the woman she
probably didn't know a lot of verses of
plant but she was implement in what she
knew from Allah to the to the best of
her ability and it just showed you that
tawheed is supposed to actually affect
change in the community
yeah Tom Eve not just in the limbs is
not just so dude in the front row and
the mass today is actually benefits like
singing about allah alone is singling
out in the favors that he's bestowed
upon he's bestowed upon me and this
woman here she's just she's showing the
beauty of his lab to this woman so much
the point where if anyone speaks ill of
Islam yeah she's not having it
imagine if that was our dowel that we
did everywhere every time he came across
a Muslim you only had a good account of
Muslim then his deep even the naysayers
even the people that may dislike it so
because not everybody's gonna love his
love yeah but least your opponent your
enemy can say yeah I you know I had such
an such an encounter with that person
and I personally had a very reason it
showed me good manners yeah I think it
was chefs allophones and who said -
there was a Gyptian ship who's asking
from the CFO's Russia a kind of notion
of a number and he said to him ask you
to tell him I'll make dua
I made what Allah makes you successful
what you doing and number two he goes
when you give him dower
if the person opposite doesn't accept
your message at least leave them neutral
don't get out while I look at you and
accepting the message not to show this
the hub is true he's fun to see you or
your arrogant man talking about I don't
did it take you a real it is not clear I
don't did it take use these little
droplets of you know the message of
Islam that eventually accept you know
guys that's about eight man that's what
I want to share with you guys I found it
profound I found it absolutely amazing
and we also lost want Allah to guide her
and guide us we're a small guide passed
my Allah and change our haka add up to
what it's supposed to
be and the back someone yeah they so
much you if I'm mistaken process it
sounds like it's like your character and
it's importantly will you let people see
Islam in you let them not hear it for
once let them see in you just wait on
that hadith as well the fact that the
police are sort of used in the map in
the Mazza is an emphasis yeah it shows i
don't like sometimes it's easy for us to
quote and it doesn't really affect
anything but is there the Prophet is
stressing this mannerism yeah and when
you look at the polite the lifestyle of
the Prophet even like I said friends and
enemies he always have the pistol
o'clock and we need to really do our
best in trying to implement that money
for easily see if we do you want us to
react to inshallah comment on the
section below
till next time goodbye